الاحتفالات في وسط شيرب وصلت الحدود من
مصر ان همم من السودان من المغرب ومن
البلاد العربيه اجمع وصل الى هنا في
الاحتفال بفوز المنتخب المغربي
[تصفيق]
للشعب المغربي والشعب القطري
وفرحه بص هيعانه المغرب انا من السودان
ان شاء الله
مغربه المنتخب
من فين من اي منطقه
انت كنت بالملعب ولا جيتي رقصا على هون
اي شوف كيف كانت الاجواء والله اجواء كانت
رائعه
الجمهور واللاعبين قدها همم اللاعب ممتاز
الله يحفظهم ويقويهم وينصرهم ان شاء الله
يلقوها في المباراه القادمه انجلترا
رح اسال هالسؤال بس في كثير لاحظت طريقه
تشجيع الذكور المغاربه للمنتخب المغربي
ولكن النساء كيف كنت تشجعوا انتم بالملعب
السيسي
وايا الاولاد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ساعد على ادمن استعداد سواء للمباراه
[تصفيق]
[ضحك]